Meet Viva Real
A partner company of Udacity
I think everyone knows why Viva Real exists,
because finding a property,
renting and buying a property is hard.
We see a great potential to organize this process,
give people more information
and assure people they
can make a good decision
about where to live.
Today we are 600 people,
we've grown a lot,
and today we have
over 5 million properties registered
for rent and for sale.
And I think  that
companies that forget
they need to constantly review
their existing ideas
and bring new things
will fail in the digital world.
We truly believe in
bringing new people, new talent,
people who bring new ideas
and think outside the box.
Professionals who are prepared,
those who are experienced,
who have technical background
they are very disputed in the market.
So how will your company,
how will Vival Real
become a company
which is irresistible enough
so that they will refuse
other offers and choose us?
Today our greatest trouble
is finding professionals
who adhere to our culture.
Who can identify
with the way we work,
with what we look for
in terms of behaviour...
Our team is arranged
by products cell.
We use effective methodologies
but we don't use
one specific methodology,
we truly believe each team
can work independently
and we standardize a few things.
We standardize
the interfaces accross teams
So the way requests
get to the teams,
the way we document
each product's needs,
and the way these teams
shoud communicate.
But the internal processes
are determined by each team.
Usually, by giving them space
we reap much more benefits than
by creating something very formal.
It's one of the few places I've worked
where I feel truly comfortable.
Which motivates me the most here
besides the freedom we have
within the Viva Real platform
are the people.
So here we have a team
that is very good and very diverse.
You end up learning a lot each day.
Learning is essential
for a tech professional.
Those who are not interested
in keeping themselves updated
will get quickly outdated.
It even becomes a matter of survival.
Especially when you wish
to work at cutting-edge companies.
I believe our partnership with Udacity
can help Viva Real find the best talent.
We look for people who are
always willing to get better
and Udacity's students
are already doing that.
We often have positions opened in data
so data analystics and data science
are openings we very often have.
An expertise area we've been always
looking at is performance marketing.
Today I have openings
for developers in our back teams
when we think about
the stacks of ruby, python...
...all you can imagine,
because we do not limit
the use of any technology.
Front development.
And for the mobile teams we use iOS, Android.
Talking about iOS we use swift.
Get ready for the market